first of all I think that if you're
asking people to sacrifice in whatever
form that takes it's really important
that people feel that that is being
imposed in a way that is fair and isn't
just being imposed on you know a few or
even worse just imposed on people that
are lower salary people really should be
the opposite you should you know try and
you know make sure that lower salary
people are the first people to get a
cost of living increase not the not the
last people and look for ways where you
can celebrate your victories you know
sort of don't don't remove that from the
organization in fact you know look for
those opportunities